a new book is shedding light on
president Trump's battle to push ahead
with one of his signature policies
securing the us-mexico border according
to the book mr. Trump suggested shooting
migrants in the legs he reportedly made
the suggestion in March during a meeting
where he also called for the entire
border to be closed to New York Times
reporters wrote the book which is
published by Simon & Schuster a division
of CBS Paula reads at the White House
Paula why did the president allegedly
make these comments Anthony earlier this
year as border crossings hit record
numbers The Times reports the president
grew increasingly frustrated with the
situation along the southern border and
intent on delivering on his campaign
promises to build a wall and deter
illegal immigration he started throwing
out some new ideas we're closing the
border they'll close it and we'll we'll
keep it close for a long time I'm not
playing games
in late March President Trump publicly
threatened to close the us-mexico border
but according to The Times reporters in
a March meeting the president's advisors
tried to turn him away from such a
drastic move he responded you're making
me look like an idiot and shouted I ran
on this it's my issue administration
officials were constantly having to kind
of walk the president back from the
precipice where he walked him back from
the edge of what could be a crisis
Michael Shearer and Julie Hirschfeld
Davis are the reporters and authors of
the book border wars
inside Trump's assault on immigration he
made all these promises he talked in
these grandiose ways about things he
wanted to do when he was in office but
then he comes in and confronts the
reality of governing the article also
details the president's other
suggestions to stem migration they want
to throw rocks at our military our
military fights back we're gonna
consider it I tell them considered or a
rifle and while he said he didn't mean
to shoot migrants that they threw rocks
at Border Patrol agents the New York
Times reports that the president later
suggested they shoot migrants in the
legs to slow them down they right he
also privately talked about fortifying a
border wall with a water-filled trench
stocked with snakes or alligators and he
wanted the wall electrified with spikes
on top that could
Pearse human flesh we've reached out to
the White House for comment on this
report but have not heard back as of
August 57 miles of border wall have been
built but hundreds of miles remain and
costs are mounting the Pentagon has
diverted approximately six point 1
billion dollars for this project Gail
all right Paula thank you